amy vous êtes prêts oui on va faire une
interview sans intérêt dans la bouche
mais on ne bouge pas pendant le king à
l'original dès que ma fille est partie
est quand même beaucoup moins de la
finale et shirel 10 mois et a rappelé la
meuf là non ah bon sa part appelé non
non je comprends pas d'ailleurs pourquoi
hop parce que je n'ai pas fini mon
numéro
peut-être fois ci tu cours - parfois
ouais c'était là la mer ou la montagne a
ajouté allan r mais ouais c'était
moyenne pas à fait répond d'autres trop
de chance sur le trop de sable trop de
trop de j'aime pas sa mère
ouais ouais t'as pas fait pas dix balles
pour le cas dit non je fais rentrer du
fioul ouais j'ai fait rentrer du chemin
alors j'en ai suffisamment pour le mois
de décembre
il me manque pour janvier normalement on
est sur le coup de tête il y avait aussi
un cousin qui va passer pour en dévoiler
saleh doit savoir combien je fais tout
le monde en parle de roide la voiture
allait fermer la tête à portée de
fermeture non justement j'ai mon arme
qui marchent plus je ne veux pas aller
où je me suis foutu au parquet un mois
ça va alors il ya un gardien tavannois
sinon ça va
moi ça va je m'en parle prix ouais ça va
t'as pas vu ma personne donc là je la
trouve que ça se passe bien ta moi ça va
mais c'est quoi en ce moment tout le
monde en parle d'un vrai d'accord mais
qui croit ces trucs là non pas trop
c'est un cd-rom combien il ya quelque
chose qui me dérange d'instruction je
sais qu'ils ont pas non non non tu
allais je me suis toujours demandé si tu
aimes et des chiens mais je me suis posé
la même question hier et j'ai glissé sur
un truc et puis je me suis dit que
j'aimais pas les chiens savent atos est
choisie moi je suis toujours dans pas on
n'a pas alloué bien sûr que ce qu'on
pense à 61,10 bien vite et chemise là
tous les lots j'ai acheté chez
d'inspirer chemises et chemisiers ben je
me suis dit que bon il fallait un petit
peu à l'aise là dedans ça va je me sens
un petit peu crispé tu vois mais serra
n'obtient pas chose a pas trop de mettre
au chaud en même temps il fait chaud ici
ouais la chose de vraiment un ça se
passe bien je fais tout le monde en
parle
organise toi c'est vrai choix bassin
chaurien méchant qui maquille monnaie
pour longtemps pour les questions
je sais pas pour les fêtes tu fais quoi
alors pour les fêtes par exemple noël
ouais et je vais probablement acheté un
sapin
les managers